lundi 12 janvier 1824
trois hommes en kapisa encadrés par des
soldats traverse la foule rassemblèrent
fort royal il se dirige vers l'échafaud
sur lequel les attend le recours au
votre marqué au fer rouge des trois
lettres ga el ghalia l'élu lattre
cyrille bissette jean baptiste boni et
louis fabien ont été condamnés le matin
même ils seront déportés comme 219
autres libres de couleur
banni de la colonie a franchi ou nelly
bras de liaison entre esclaves et becker
ils sont désormais plus nombreux que les
colons et constituent un groupe de plus
en plus puissants qui osent aujourd'hui
et réclamer l'égalité avec les blancs
pour l'instant la législation leur
interdit notamment d'occuper certains
métiers de porter de l'or où certains
vêtements
non pas le droit de s'habiller comme les
blancs comme les blanches et non il ya
des tissus que sa der dîner vêtements
sont interdits ils n'ont même pas le
droit aux mêmes places à l'église une
discrimination dénoncée jusqu'à paris où
la cause des libres de couleur est
entendue une brochure à réclamant le
changement est ainsi imprimer en france
afin d'être distribués dans une rue un
texte qui ne demandent pas la fin du
système esclavagiste car les gens de
couleur libres sont souvent eux mêmes
propriétaires d'esclaves
c'est le cas de cyril charles auguste
bis est un négociant mulâtre neveu
naturel de joséphine de beauharnais qui
s'est illustré l'année précédente
en réprimant la révolte des esclaves du
garbet avec les milices de couleurs de
formes royal il sera donc accusé d'avoir
diffusé le texte martinique avec l'aide
de ses complices et la répression est
terrible
la justice coloniale littéralement
écraser le mouvement
mais en 1830 la nouvelle révolution
française relance le débat et les droits
des hommes de couleur livres sont
finalement reconnu et cette révolution
de 1830 roy connaît la fin des lois
somptuaires
on connaît le doigt le côté des noms de
blanc si on veut et reconnaît les droits
politiques des libres de couleur
ces nouvelles règles seront appliquées à
environ un an plus tard grâce à la
détermination du gouverneur jean henri
joseph du potet qui s'attirent aussitôt
la haine des békés
mais l'histoire est en marche et les
mules lettres deviennent eux aussi
favorables à l'abolition cette période à
sens c'est que beaucoup de libres de
couleur qui au départ était très
esclavagiste commencent à se rendre
compte qu'il faut changer de position et
c'est le renversement de situation qui
fait que beaucoup de libres de couleur
se rendent compte qu pour changer la
société coloniale temps à la martinique
à la guadeloupe
mais il faut l'abolition des réfugiés en
france
l'iss est finit également par embrasser
la cause abolitionniste en 1835 publiant
dans sa revue des colonies un article
réclamant sans ambiguïté la libération
immédiate des esclaves aux antilles le
début
nouveau combat